begin now with the coronavirus cases
stacking up and getting tested very much
still a challenge people all across the
valley having a hard time finding that
free testing or just trying to find a
place where there isn't a huge line
hector mejia live this morning from the
va hospital in north las vegas where
they're making some changes hector
good morning john the va hospital here
saying that they're seeing a sharp
increase in the number of emergency room
visits related to kovitz so the
procedures as far as testing for
veterans are changing starting this
morning out there in the distance you
can see those tents set up that is being
set up this morning what they're calling
a covet evaluation tent set up here at
the southwest corner of the campus and
it's been a challenge all across the
valley to find free testing starting
today here at the veterans
medical center veterans who are coming
down here with covet symptoms should
first report to the covet evaluation
tent you just saw rather than the
emergency department however resources
are still limited so testing is only for
veterans with serious symptoms the
facility will not test those who do not
have symptoms or
who only have mild symptoms and this is
happening after the biden administration
promised to make home testing kits
available
the hope is for them to start shipping
half a billion of those out by january
15th and there are many more walk-up
sites available all across the valley
you just have to make an appointment
through the southern nevada health
district still ahead of the next half
hour we'll talk with a spokesperson
about exactly what they are seeing and
also visitation is changing here for
those who plan to come down here to
visit a patient reporting live hector
mejia live local now